[Musique]
j'avais 8 ans que le maire est morte
elle adorait parcourir le monde
déterrer le passé
il venait tout en nous voir puis un jour
tout a basculé
la vue de trouver un objet il le voulait
il m'aurait tué moi aussi je me suis
enfui
[Applaudissements]
le monde change c'était près d'un
trident
rien ne peut résister à ça
nous sommes londres
[Applaudissements]
amen
avant de mourir
la mère m'a dit qu'elle craignait
valentine's et que s'il lui arrivait
quoi que ce soit je devais de trouver
pour que tu l'arrêtent
elle peut poser problème si elle tient
de sa mère héritière que feras tu
lorsque tu auras trouvé ce terreau jo
je la tuerais
il est ici
dans le jeu de la survie c'est la
victoire assurée
[Musique]
je savais que tu me lâches à tétouan
arrêt court
tu es sûr de vouloir y aller il le faut
pour monnaire
tu la regardes et tout ce que tu vois ce
sont des lignes saillantes
mais elle est tout autre chose hein elle
est belle et étonnante et très très rare
[Musique]